[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar impacting sepsis outcomes using
multitask fda cleared application for
rapid microbial id direct from positive
blood culture
i am sidney mcneil of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by brooker microbiology and
diagnostics division
to learn more visit brooker.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many as as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the top of your screen
to obtain your credits
i would like to now welcome our speaker
felicia meda mt ascp
senior technologist 2 microbiology
laboratory leahy hospital and medical
center burlington massachusetts
felicia you may now begin your
presentation
so thank you for that introduction i'm
just going to reintroduce myself again
so my name is felicia meda i am a senior
tech 2 tech senior tech 2 at leahey
hospital medical center in burlington
massachusetts
we serve about 3 000 patients daily
through our clinic in the hospital
we have almost 400 inpatient beds we
have an ambulatory care center and we
just opened up a level 2 trauma center
that runs 24 hours our emergency
department
we are teaching hospital of tufts
university school of medicine and we do
have many physicians that teach have
teaching assignments at harvard medical
school and boston university school of
medicine
so these are some of the objectives that
i will be discussing today
we're going to go over
the maldi tof and how the rapid
identification
works for positive blood cultures
i'll talk a little bit about the fda
cleared application versus an ltd
laboratory developed test
i will discuss the cost savings
for using maldi-tof and molecular and
how it helps
with biochemical testing and i will also
describe
how the rapid sepsi typer can directly
influence the treatment path that would
be of the patients
so in our department uh we have a
regular routine microbiology department
we have a rapid room for testing where
we do rapid throats covert testing
herpes respiratory panels we do all that
on molecular platforms
we also perform c diff and chica toxins
in this
rapid room we also
have three other labs that belong to the
microbiology department parasitology
mycobacteriology and mycology
we have a total of about 21
technologists that work in this
particular laboratory um we have a first
shift that is from 7 00 a.m to 3 30 p.m
and then our second shift techs come in
around 3 or 3 30 and work till 11 30 or
midnight to cover our second shift
so pretty much the day shift covers the
benches they we have a blood bench a
respiratory bench that we also do stool
yeasts and throats on we have a urine
bench we have a combination of aerobic
anaerobic bench we have the rapid room
that i described earlier we have a
planting area and again our parasitology
and then on my mycobacteriology and
mycology departments
as
well so this the text network seven to
first shift excuse me they cover all of
these benches during the day
for our second shift um there's four
technologists that work for the most
part um one full time and the other
three are part-time
they also pull blood cultures
they do perform the sepsi typer they
read urine cultures they process
specimens they also perform all the
rapid testing in the rapid room and as
well as c diff and shiga toxins
a third shift does pull positive bloods
that's part of our core lab but they do
not perform the sepsi type er through
the evening shift um they pull the blood
still put them
to the auger that's needed and when we
come in in the morning our first shift
will take the blood aliquots and do the
sexy typer which we'll talk about that
in a little bit
so a little bit about our life before
maldi um
biochemicals and i don't automated
instrumentation was always used so it
would take us you know between 24 to 48
hours before we would actually get that
identification
and anaerobes as you know take a little
bit longer to grow so by the time the
blood culture goes positive or any
organism so to speak not just blood
cultures it takes a couple days to grow
and then using biochemicals or discs or
whatever for the anaerobes it probably
takes at least 48 hours
before we can get an identification for
anaerobes
these are just some of the biochemicals
obviously that we used to use
our automated systems
so maldi came
into our laboratory in
probably march i believe it was of 2015
and by the time we finished our
validation we had the implementation up
and running it was june of 2015. so it
took us about three months to get this
instrument validated
with multiple technologists that worked
on it
and then we were ready to go in june
so
the impact that the maldi has had on our
laboratory is
has been
such an asset
the technologists really rely on this
instrument um it's great for rapid
same-day identification we do use this
on all of our benches
so it's a great tool that you know you
have the organism that's growing you can
get it
plated on the target put it in the
instrument and you're getting an
identification
fairly quickly at least by the end of
the day where biochem biochemicals and
instrumentation before you know you're
talking at least 24 to 48 hours you know
you're not sure if the biochemicals work
or if it takes a little longer depending
on what the organism is you know it
could take up to that 48 hour total
turnaround time so it's a great tool
where it is very helpful for our
pharmacy and infectious disease
departments
it really helps them to determine what
they're going to do for the therapy of
their patients and we have also found
that using the maldi-tof with the rapid
identification it is decreasing the
hospital length of stay by about two and
a half days
so i'm going to go over a little bit of
the biotype i'm all the type of workflow
so we have multiple technologists that
work
in the laboratory and everybody is on
their own benches so everybody has their
own target that they spot
and
each each bench is responsible for
identifying the plates the organisms
that are on the plates that are in front
of them and you know everybody is works
great as a team to decide who's going to
go on the maldives and taking turns um
but the blood brunch always does have
priority that is the first
target that usually goes on in the
morning so we can get the
identification right out to the
clinicians
so they can
change treat use it however they'd like
for their therapy for their patients
so this is what our workflow looked like
prior to
implementation of the maldi and sepsi
typer
positive blood would alert
we would pull it from the instrument
perform our gram stain aliquot 3ml of
blood into our tube
read the gram stain and then
decide what
plates
biochemicals we're going to use
for whatever organism we see with the
gram stain and then we would also make
the phone call to the floor provider
clinician wherever it needs to go to let
them know what we see growing
in the blood culture
so if we
performed a gram stain and we saw
gram-positive cocci in clusters
we would plate that to a sheep blood
auger
we would add the
furozodine stone sorry
not great with the words there um disc
and that is to rule out micrococcus so
we do put that on
our gram positives
then we would also take three drops of
the blood and put that into a tube co
egg and we're ruling out staph aureus
with that
if we were to see gram-positive cocci in
pairs and chains
then we are going to plate that to a
sheep and a chocolate plate
and we would add an oxygen disk on that
one again that's just to rule out strep
pneumo
we would also take three drops of blood
and add that to a bioelectron tube and a
salt and again that would be to rule out
enterococcus so this is so that we would
have some type of an identification at
that 24 hour mark using these
biochemicals
for our gram-negative rods um
we would plate it to a sheep a chocolate
mcconkey and a cna
if it was from the anaerobic bottle we
would also add an anaerobic blood plate
and that would go into our anaerobic
chamber
if we saw a gram-positive rod then that
we would just plate to a sheet plate and
also a bioesco and tube
to rule out listeria
so at the 24 hour mark so we're going to
let that incubate for 24 hours we would
look at the plate the growth on the
plates and if we were able to identify
identify the organism at this time then
we would phone that to the floor we
would give them an update to let them
know
what grew out
if we weren't then we would have to go
to our automated instrumentation
and
chances are that's going to take us
another 24 hours
for the automated instrumentation to
give us an identification sometimes it
takes a little bit longer depending on
the organism so
looking at this from start to finish
prior to maldi
we're looking at about 48 hours until we
get any type of identification
so now if we move on and we implement
our maldi and our sepsi typer the
workflow is similar to a point so where
positive blood will alert
we will pull it off we will make our
gram stain we will
aliquot our 3mls of blood
we will read the gram stain
but here what we would do is now we
would set up our sepsi typer
and hopefully have an identification and
we're now able to give the
identification
the same day
as the blood culture was pulled from the
instrument therefore bypassing
biochemicals and waiting 24 hours before
we have any type of identification
so here's just a slide to show you
how it kind of works you have your blood
collection system it goes into your
blood culture
instrumentation
this is the sepsi typer kit that you see
here
and then from subsidy typer
goes on to the target the target then
gets put into the maldi
and just to let you know the maldi the
ca clinical application side
this is all fda approved and they have
approved 488
species of bacteria in yeast
that are on the clinical application
side so if we
these organisms are identified we're
able to
put these results out into the computer
um with a with a confirmed confirmation
okay so in october of 2017
brooker
had a sepsi typer that came out and we
did a validation on this
um so this was great for us
and
we did our own in-house validation
it's on the ruo side which is the
research use only side
and what we did is we used 40 gram
negatives
40 gram positives and we did not use any
more than 10 of the same organism
this was performed over a period of
three months
and
we were able to identify 93 percent of
the gram-negative organisms and 67
percent of the gram-positive organisms
and broker had stated that
the identification system should work at
least 70 of the time which we did prove
this was a little under for our gram
positives but what we did is we
continued to monitor it over the year
and of the 708 samples that we tested we
did have a 73 73 identification rate so
it did
perform up to their expectations
um in 2019 they did come out with a
rapid sample preparation this eliminated
the tube extraction
which made this so much more quicker for
us in identification so due to already
having a full
validation we decided we were just going
to go with a limited validation
in april when we started to use this so
for this one we just did five gram
positives five gram negatives this was a
quick validation it only took about two
days to get this done and the
identification was successful at 100
percent
of all organisms that we used
the difference between this rapid sample
preparation versus the original sepsi
typer is
because we were doing an extraction when
we were doing our workflow we decided to
batch our blood cultures
we would call the gram stain but we
would batch
the blood and when we had a decent
amount then we would perform a pepsi
typer so the difference is now is with
this rapid sample because we don't have
that extraction anymore we're able to do
this as they come in
without having to wait in batch and now
it's just done
individually as it happens
so the impact of using the sepsi typer
because it's still on the research side
we always would put presumptive id after
the organism
we would have the gram stain within that
hour
be able to do a sepsi typer put the
organism in but we would call it
presumptive id so pharmacy and
infectious disease we're still able to
see the identification
and be able to treat their patients
accordingly and it also did help
decrease that hospital length of stay
some of the disadvantages
is that it did take up take us a little
bit to get the validation done
we did have to create our own procedures
we were not able to build this because
it was research only
there wasn't any software that broker
had for the sepsi type or on the
research side
and because we put the organisms in as a
presumptive id
on the next day so at 24 hours when they
grew on the media we then had to use the
maldi
to confirm the identification that we
got from the sepsi type on the research
side
okay so i did speak with one of our
infectious disease physicians and asked
him if he could give me his thought
his thoughts on our sepsi type or system
and
getting identification earlier
and he said to me quote patients are put
on therapy a day earlier due to the
rapid sepsi type end quotes
he's like i said one of our physicians
infectious diseases physicians at leahey
and he had a shazam moment which i will
talk about on the next slide
so dr m's shazam moment
we had a positive blood culture
that the gram stain showed gram-positive
cocci
in pairs and chains
we did our rapid sepsi typer
and it identified as beta-hemolytic
strep group a so we were like wow that's
kind of interesting and then we kind of
looked into the patient a little further
we like to look and see if we can try to
figure out where they're getting their
sepsis from and we found that this
patient also had a wound culture and two
um times two
so the technologist that was working on
this wound culture
saw they were very very tiny pinpoints
on the argor and figured they would just
re-incubate it for another day so that
they could work on it at that 24 hour
point well when we discovered that this
patient actually had group a strep in
their blood we said let's pull the
plates out let's see if we can work on
it let's see if we can get an
identification and sure enough we were
able to get an identification and in
both of the wound cultures that they
sent they were group a strep so it was
kind of a really cool thing for us to
see in the laboratory and for the
information to be given to dr m so he
could
treat his patient and now he knows kind
of where it's coming from that it was
into you know it was in the wound site
and now it's in his blood so it was just
a really great moment for us because
without that rapid pepsi typer we
wouldn't have known we would have just
reported gram-positive cocci and pears
and chains and we would have had to wait
24 hours the wounded waited 24 hours
and you know it could have been
detrimental to this patient's health
so in 2021
burger came out with the sepsi type of
kit us ivd
so this is a kit that now we can use on
the clinical side
so this was fda cleared for the clinical
application so what does this mean for
the laboratory
so fda cleared products are now
chargeable so this is great for us
because now that it's on the clinical
side we are now able to charge versus
when it was on the research side it was
a non-billable and we were unable to
charge for this product
so benefits of it being fda cleared um i
already mentioned a couple
um
saying that we are we can bill it now
it was nice because now it's just a
limited verification because we already
did the major the major validation
earlier
um it's
on the clinical application side
it allows us to reference that library
of 488 species so now we can say that we
don't have to use the word presumptive
id anymore
we don't have to confirm the id the next
day
when the organism grows we look at it
and if the morphology and everything
looks the same then we know that maldi
identified it correctly
we have now an algorithm
and there's new software that's
dedicated to this new kit
that we'll go over and some slides ahead
this is the kit
you can see that it does it has 50 tests
per box
we stored at room temperature the
expiration date is a two-year
manufacturing expiration date and three
months after opening it which i can tell
you we never hit that three-month mark
because with the amount of blood
cultures that we have that go positive
we're able to to get through these kits
quick kits quickly
um the components inside is the are the
is the lysis buffer
the washing buffer it has the micro
center huge tubes and then there's a
quick guide that if you want to leave
that out and have your technologist use
that or make a quick reference guide
yourself whatever works for you
we do keep it in the box if the
technologists choose to look at that and
we also do have a separate little quick
cheat sheet if they want that
so this is how we perform
the sepsi typer in the
laboratory we pull the blood off
we have our aliquot
we take one ml and we put it into the
eppendorf tube
from there we add 200 microliters of the
lysis buffer
we mix that and then we centrifuge that
for two minutes
we then discard the supernatant
and we add one ml of the washing buffer
we'll mix that
and then we centrifuge that for one
minute we then discard that supernatant
and we should see a pellet on the bottom
and that is what we would use to put on
the target
and that's what we use for the
identification
sometimes we don't always see that
pellet
and
we have used just we keep like a little
bit of the aliquot of the fluid on the
bottom of it we'll pull up the
supernatant but leave a little bit of
the fluid and we actually have been able
to get an identification from just that
fluid even if it doesn't have the pellet
in there so
you know we we try it anyways and then
if it doesn't work from there we can
continue on and use the extraction
and um we will nine times out of ten get
an identification once we go to the
extraction but most of the time we will
get an identification
at this point
in the process
so the workflow
flexibility um again
the bottles are stable for 24 hours once
they come off the instrument so you have
up to 24 hours to
aliquot and run your sepsi taper
um
this is just how we do it here in our
laboratory and of course you know from
laboratory to laboratory it can
be used differently but we perform our
gram stain we subculture it and then we
aliquot it for the sepsi typer um again
we have there's 488 organisms that
you're going to be able to
use for identification to match up
and the pellet is stable for one hour
the other thing is if you can get that
pellet onto the target and you put your
matrix on then that is stable for 24. so
even if you're not able to run that
target
if it's the end of the shift or
something happens or
the maldi goes down god forbid
as long as you put it on the target and
you put the matrix on top of it
then you're good to go for 24 hours
um and then once we get our
identification i've really talked about
this yet but we'll get into this a
little bit more
it can be reflex to molecular testing
for any resistance markers if needed and
if you have that molecular testing in
your laboratory
so there is a dedicated sepsi type or
software now that it is fda approved and
it's on the clinical side
um you would put in the patient
sample
or you can scan it in
we would then change the standard to
sepsi typer which is in a drop down um
i'll show you that in the next couple of
slides
and then we have our sepsi type the
sepsi type algorithm is applied
it would identify if it's a mixed
culture alert
and it shows you the different scores
and that will determine whether it's a
reportable identification or not which
i'll talk to you about in the next
couple slides
so here's
the scoring that i was just speaking of
as you can see a high confidence
identification is a 1.8 to a 3.0
we will see a color green on the screen
um a 1.6 to a 1.79 is low confidence and
then anything below
1.6 we really don't take that into
consideration at all
so what ends up happening is as long as
we get that 1.8 or higher
we can report that organism out we have
had situations where at that 1.79 the
1.78
so if that gives us an identification
there we can try and move forward to the
extraction and see if we can get it a
little higher if unfortunately we can't
then we would just leave the gram stain
result in the computer
but we do have infectious disease rounds
where id comes down and we do update
them on their critical patients any
positive blood cultures so at this point
we would verbally let them know that the
sepsi type or gave them an
identification of
x but we can't put it in the computer so
that way we can at least help guide them
and give them direction
99 of the time if it's in that yellow
and we get that low confidence we are on
the right track but it's just not
something that we can confirm and we're
positive with so we cannot put that
information into the system to get into
the patient's chart but like i said we
will let infectious disease know that
you know
on the qt this is what's going on but we
can't put it in the computer and you
know they're very grateful that we even
have that information for them
so this is what the screen would look
like if you had a mixed culture um this
one is showing you that the staph aureus
is a 1.98 but there's a crying bacterium
in there at a 2.5
so what happens with the situation like
this if we run into something like this
we have our technologists
see a senior tattoo or
our
manager and what we would do then is we
would look at the gram stain if the gram
stain was only gram positive cocci in
clusters and we got this 1.98 steph
aureus we would sign it out as a
staphorious
if we saw that it was mixed
by looking at the identification from
the model d
and then re
viewing the gram stain and we see maybe
some grim positive rods in there then we
probably would not do any identification
in our laboratory if it's a mixed
culture so if we see poly microbes in
the gram stain we do not put it on pepsi
typer we really only will use the model
d and the sepsi typer if it is just one
organism in the gram stain
um
other places may do it differently this
is just what our algorithm is and this
is how we've set up our procedure
and like i said typically we do not run
into this i think maybe we have seen
this once
since we've been using this system
so again
the scoring of this it has to be above
1.8
and if there is no identification i kind
of talked about this we would go into
that full extraction
um
and 9 times out of 10 it will work but
there definitely are times that it's not
going to again you know it's a 70
identification rate
okay so here's a case where we ran the
sepsi typer
and as you can see it says no peaks
and under the score it says 0.00 so this
would be something where
this was the rapid pepsi typer so there
was no extraction we would do the
extraction on it and then we would see
if we could get those numbers higher
if we can't then this is a case where we
would put it on our molecular instrument
and get the identification off of our
molecular instrument
so now this next slide
what you can see is there was no match
so no organism identification
from the clinical application side but
if it does find something on the
research side you will see that come up
as an unvalidated result
and in this situation we had a no
organism identification possible but yet
on the research side it gave us an
identification of a bacillus which was
greater than that 1.8 so in this
situation what we have done because
we've validated the research side we are
able to put that in as a bacillus
species not anthraces and we would just
use that code presumptive id because it
is on the research site
so our algorithm in our hospital when we
perform our sepsi typer is in the
these next few slides so i'll talk you
through them they may seem a little
confusing
so bear with me and hopefully you'll be
able to follow
my direction
so when we have the first bottle
of a set that is positive with
gram-negative rods gram-positive cocci
or large gram-positive rods we
automatically do a sepsi type
if the second set turns positive so if
there's two sets that are drawn on the
same day the first set goes positive we
do our sepsi typer if the second set
turns positive from the same day
we will not do a sepsi typer we're
assuming that it's the same organism
from what we just identified from the
first set unless it's a coed negative
staff in our hospital our algorithm
states that we look at the species of
the coed negative staff to decide
whether we're going to do an ast on it
or not so therefore we look at the sets
and we determine from there whether
we're going to do a sepsi type or not
if it is a new bottle from a different
day with gram-negative rods we will set
up the sepsi typer because we want to
confirm that it's the same gram-negative
if it's gram-positive cocci we will not
set it up unless again it's that coed
negative staff and it's greater than
three days old
and then if it's a gram-positive rod we
do not set it up so we really focus on
that very first set and then if it's the
next day depending on the organism will
depend on how we're going to use the
system
so just to show you how
this sepsi typer kit
is used as a front line method
we make the gram stain we do the sepsi
typer
read the gram stain so as the gram stain
is drying we're setting up the sepsi
typer we read the gram stain
so now we have an idea of what the
organism is going to be
we will hopefully get the identification
from the sepsi
and if we can get all this done within
an hour then we can phone it and let
them know what that identification is if
we know it's going to take us a little
longer than an hour if something comes
up if we have too many blood cultures if
something just gets in our way then we
will automatically call that gram stain
and we will not wait for the sepsi typer
one of the great things about sepsi
typer is if we're reading our gram stain
and we're not sure
is it gram-negative rods is it
gram-positive rods is it a gram-variable
rod then we really do rely on sepsi
typer and that really can help us guide
give us a good guidance as to what this
gram stain is and there have been quite
a few times that we have said let's just
wait and see what pepsi gives us for an
id and that way we know what the actual
gram stain is
so another great feature of what that
sepsi type or can do for us as far as
identification of organisms
and then depending on what the organism
is will depend on whether we're going to
reflex that to our molecular testing
which i will show you in the next slide
so our algorithm again for gram-positive
cocci so we have a sepsi typer
that gives us an identification
of staph aureus enterococcus or the
combination of strep midas pneumo we
will automatically put that on our
molecular instrument
because we're looking for any gene
markers so whether it's a vre we're
looking for mrsa and
then depending on that identification if
it is a vre if it's mssa or mrsa
between the hours of nine to five we do
page our pharmacy so that way it will
give them a heads up as to what the
organism is
and they can continue with therapy or
discontinue therapy as need be
if the sepsi typer does not give us an
identification
we will do the extraction if we still do
not get an identification then we will
put it on our molecular instrumentation
to see if we can get an identification
if it is a coed negative staff so sepsi
types it gives us any type of coag
negative staff then we just stop there
there's no need for us to put it on a
molecular instrument and we will page
pharmacy at that point to let them know
that it is a coed negative staff
if it gives any other type of
identification
as long as that score is above 1.8 and
it's not an organism that we would be
looking for gene marker resistance then
we do not put it on our molecular
instrument again we use our molecular
instrument for identification
if we can't get the sepsi type to work
and for any gene marker resistance
so for gram-negative rods
same type of algorithm perform our sepsi
typer there's no identification for
sepsi typer it goes right to our
molecular instrument
to the slide if you look at the box on
the left the right however you're
looking at the system
if any of those organisms are identified
by sepsi typer we automatically put it
on a molecular instrument and we're
looking for that gene marker resistance
if we find any resistance markers then
we do page pharmacy if there are no
markers then there is no page 2 pharmacy
any other identification that is not in
that bubble that you see we do not go
any further it does not go on the
molecular instrument and again it has to
be above that 1.8 in order for us to
identify it
and put it into our system and then we
do not go any further
so just a
quick overview of what we did for our
verification using
the
sepsi type on the ca side again just
very limited 15 gram positive 15 gram
negatives 10 anaerobes
this took us about four weeks to get
this validation
we had 31 of 40 were concordant with the
expected results but of but nine of
those 40 did not give us an
identification so we excluded those
from
our data
due to
there is no expectation
that this test will provide
identification 100 of the time so
therefore our scores were above that
70 again
so here are some statistics from april
to june
um we did 194
sepsi typer ids
of the 194 170 of them were identified
so again 87
identification so well above what broker
states
and then just a little bit of data just
to show you um how it's worked in our
hospital so
the number of sepsi type identified that
we had to put on our molecular
instrument for resistance detection so
there was 96 organisms
so that was a 49.5
percent
identification on sepsi typer
that 49.5 percent were sent to
the
molecular
instrumentation sorry
for the number of sepsi type of subsea
typers that were sent to molecular
because there was no identification
there were 24 organisms so that was a 12
12 of them were sent
and then for the number of sepsi type
identified
on
the number of 70 diapers
sorry the number identified by sepsi
typer that we did not have to put on a
molecular platform was 74. so 38
of our organisms did not have to go onto
our molecular instrument
i know that was a little confusing but
hopefully looking at the chart you'll
understand what i was trying to get out
of my mouth
so this gave us a total savings on our
molecular test kits of eleven thousand a
little over eleven thousand dollars that
we saved over a three month period
so going back to the other chart if you
saw 74 did not have to go on to our
molecular testing at 150 for a price
test
kit that we use or price per test i
should say
so you can see the savings that we had
just over a three month period
so lastly i'm just going to get into a
few case studies just to show you
how this has impacted us here
at leahy
so the first case study we had a blood
culture flag positive
the gram stain result
was gram-negative rods
we did a sepsi typer and we ended up
with b frag well as you know b frag is
an anaerobe
when we reported this we reported it out
as gram-negative rods now we can't say
that it's an anaerobic or negative rod
because at this point we do not know
so with gram-negative rods
then we were able to perform the sepsi
typer it gave us the b frog's result
which we were then able to update
and we were able to update it in the
computer in the patient's chart
and therefore id pharmacy was then able
to
change
the antibiotic therapy
to
an appropriate
antibiotic for this particular organism
so again typically gram-negative rod
they're going to choose one set
of their they're going to choose one
type of therapy for a gram negative rod
and as you can imagine if it's an
anaerobe they need to choose a different
one so this was great for them to see
definitely helped provide in patient
care
the next case study was positive blood
culture flagged and this one
was gram-positive cocci in clusters and
it was suggestive of stuff
so this is how we report it if we see
gram-positive cocci and clusters we
always say suggesting stuff if that's
what it looks like to us
again performed the sepsi typer
and
came out with aerococcus urane so
you can imagine how surprised we were
when this result came out we're thinking
it's going to come off as a staphorious
or cognitive staff so to see that it was
an aerococcus that really blew a lot of
our text minds we were just like oh my
god this is just amazing
and aerocaucus is one of the organisms
that you wouldn't is not on our
molecular platform so even if we put it
on there we still wouldn't have been
able to identify it so this was great
because here we are and id and pharmacy
and the patient's care team is thinking
they're dealing with some type of a
staff and now we're able to give them
this identification that it's an air
carcass which is great because again now
they can change that antibiotic therapy
so without sepsi typer
this patient would have been on staff
therapy
until the next day when we said oh no
this is definitely not a staff
so again just
great things with the sexy typer
and then the last one
it flagged positive
it was gram-positive rods so again that
goes into the system
as gram-positive rods we performed our
sepsi taper and again
amazement it ended up being an
actinitignum shalei so formerly known as
an actinobaculum shalei
so this one was kind of interesting it's
not a bug that we typically see in
our um positive blood cultures for
sepsis so we did look a little further
into the patient's history and we
noticed that we did have a urine culture
that did have greater than 100 000 cfus
per ml pinpoint colonies so because the
colonies were so small
the technologist said i'm going to
reincubate this plate for tomorrow and
then we'll see
what it looks like
so by getting having that actinotignum
shali identification from the sepsi
typer on day two the colonies were a
little bit bigger they were able to use
the monalde on the colony and they also
confirmed that the actinotinum was in
the urine so this was great because we
were able to inform the clinician that
the positive blood had the actinotignum
the urine did have greater than a
hundred thousand but it was pinpoint but
at least now the clinician is able to
connect the dots and understand where
the sepsis is coming from so
just some great work that we were able
to do using the subsidy typer
and providing the clinicians and
pharmacy with all the information that
they need to be able to help treat and
change therapy for these patients as
needed
so in conclusion
as you've heard me discuss throughout
the talk the sepsi typer kit is an
extreme asset for us here at leahey used
as a frontline method for our positive
blood cultures
the results are determined within
minutes i mean we're talking you know a
good 20 minutes compared to the 24 to 48
hours
once that blood culture flags positive
due to the fda clearance we are now able
to report 488 organisms and not have to
have a presumptive id we don't have to
go back the next day and do a maldi to
confirm it
it definitely provides actionable
results for our closing clinicians in a
timely manner as well as our pharmacy
it's decreasing the hospital length of
stay by two and a half days
we definitely decrease the amount of
biochemicals that we order so this is
another significant savings
and
as well as the savings that we have
using molecular
and then it is a great tool for our
antimicrobial stewardship
and these are just the products that i
discussed just a quick review so it is
the maldi biotyper
system in the sepsi typer kit
we do use it on the clinical application
side
and that's
all i have to say it's a wonderful tool
for our hospital we don't know what we
would do without this
we love it it's great
i just cannot say enough about this so i
thank you for your attendance thank you
for letting me come today to discuss the
model top and at this point i will take
any questions that are out there and do
my best to answer them
all right thank you felicia for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
let's get started our first question is
does your lab use any sequencing assays
for id for example in those cases where
the maldi is not adequately
discriminatory so
the only thing that we the only reason
we would have a discriminatory result
would be if it's lower than 1.8
um so if it is lower than 1.8 like i
discussed in the presentation we would
do
an extraction if the extraction didn't
work then we would put it to our
molecular instrument
um
so at that point if we don't get a
result from that either then we just
leave it in as the gram stain result and
we wait for the organism to grow the
next day
perfect thank you our next question is
you mentioned 70
correct identification but later 87
have you improved your rate of
identification as you worked with the
kit
we have so as the technologists became
more comfortable with it we did see
an increase in our percentage rate we
also figured out what we could do to
tweak it what would work best for us and
what wouldn't
sometimes you know just using that
extraction actually increased the
identification
a lot of times we will see gram
positives give us a little bit more
difficult time so we will have to go
into that extraction
method versus just doing the straight
rapid
all right thank you our next question is
we tried the fda approved kit and had
very poor results for gram positive 30
id did you experience the same do you
have any tips for us
so unfortunately we did not we actually
had very good results um and like i said
i think it was because we did the sepsi
and we if we didn't get it from the
rapid we went into the extraction i'm
not sure if you did the extraction
method with it
but once we did the extraction method
then we did have you know
decent results enough to get us over
that 70 mark
all right thank you our next question is
can a generalist mlt
able be able to perform this
yes absolutely
perfect next question how do we manage
contamination rates
um contamination rates as far as the
sepsi typer i'm not sure we i don't we
have a technologist that looks at our
blood cultures and looks at
contamination rates
so that really is more dependent on our
blood cultures not the sepsi typer i
can't really speak to the fact that
we've had contamination rate for the
actual sepsi type or kit in performing
the test if that answers the question
all right thank you next question is how
do you transfer the pellet from the
micro centrifuge tube to the maldi
target
so there's a couple different ways you
can do it um we usually just use the
toothpick that we would use to spot with
the regular organism
sometimes if it's really
liquidy
then we'll just use that one microliter
the pipet that we would use
for using putting the matrix on it so we
do it either way we can use the
toothpick or we can use the one
microlight one microliter pipet
wonderful thank you
next question what issues have you
encountered with the kid what percentage
of miss ids have you seen
i can honestly say we have not had a
misidentification with this kit we
haven't had any issues with the kit the
only issue
that we would have is if we got too low
and we didn't notice it and we didn't
have it on order and we needed to order
it quickly overnight that's pretty much
it but we have not had any
misidentifications
all right next question
what percentage of samples need
extraction
that i don't know off the top of my head
um
if i had to guess maybe 20 percent it's
for our laboratory and our technologists
it's really not a high number
all right thank you
next question what's the advantage of
maldi over target specific amplification
by pcr
so that just goes to
um
looking at the cost savings um
which was in my slide
all right thank you
next question i might have misunderstood
the rationale but can you clarify again
why the nine non-identified specimens
were excluded during your verification
of the sepsi typo verification
so they were excluded because they
weren't misidentified we just didn't get
any identification
so therefore we took those out to look
at our numbers because we're not going
to put something in where it doesn't
have any type of an identification if it
gave us a misidentification then it
would have been included in the numbers
perfect
next question have you had any supply
issues
um
no just like i said if we forget to
order that's really the only only supply
issue that we've ever had
all right next question
did you identify any yeast from the
blood cultures
um that was the only issue that we had
so we do not use it for yeast if we do
get a yeast we will go straight to our
molecular instrument
all right
next question
i have heard that the maldi has a
difficult differentiating esmidis versus
s
pneumo have you seen this are there any
other related issues
yes um we have run into that and that we
will see
so if we
run across a strap miter slash strep
pneumo we will not do anything with it
we will leave it in the in the
report as gram-positive cocci impairs in
chains suggestive of
streptococcus and then we wait for that
to grow on the plate the next day and we
will put that optician disc on so we
will have an identification of the 24
hours if it is a strep pneumonia
perfect thank you
next question is what is the percent of
mixed contaminated blood cultures in
your lab
i don't have that off the top of my head
all right let's see
next question during your validation did
you run into any misidentification and
how did you handle it
um i
can honestly say we did not have any
misidentification if anything we just
had low scores
all right
next question what issues have you
encountered with the kit what percentage
oh i apologize i believe we asked that
question already let's move on to
another this one says do you have any
suggestions to provide a laboratory just
starting the validation process
for ca sepsi typer
um suggestions we you know i it's hard
to say i guess it would be whatever
works for you um
we gathered the organisms that we wanted
to see if it was going to identify them
and then we had multiple technologists
work on it so that we knew different
people would be able to use this we
didn't want to have it to just be one
certain technologist doing it
you know using the extraction kit in the
formic acid is key because some of the
organisms do have that thicker cell wall
and without that formic acid to help
break it down sometimes you won't get
the identification so formic acid does
have a lot to do with the identification
you know you could reach out to me if
there's questions that you have
um and i could help you
help guide you or you know help you get
through or figure it out you know just
not sure what it is you're looking for
perfect thank you next question which
gram-positive bacteria is having trouble
with good identification
um sometimes our staff um staph aureus
will tend sometimes um collect negative
stats it's really just those two that
tend to give us that
issue um so like i said we do with the
formic acid that does help but sometimes
it doesn't help enough that we have to
do the extraction on the staff
perfect next question how far
this how far is this system good at
identifying fungal sepsis
we actually just got through validating
that for um
for our fungal organisms we are not
using it for fungal sepsis so like i
said if we do get a yeast
that goes straight to the molecular
instrument but we just validated our
maldi top four fungal elements in our
mycology lab
perfect thank you next question are the
ranges different for the c-a-r-u-o
acceptable cut-offs from the sexy type
of cutoffs
no they are not they're the same
all right
next is do you
use disposable targets or reusable
targets
we have the reusable targets that we use
in our main lab but um we actually do
use this for mycobacteriology as well
and the mycobacteriology uses the
disposables so we use both
perfect
all right it looks like we have a couple
questions left next is what happens if
blood cold is positive after 5 pm
so like i said our second shift will run
the sepsi typer so our sepsi typer will
get run up until 11 pm
and then anything after 11 pm
will um be held for us in the morning so
if the bottle goes positive again like i
said you have that 24-hour period we
will take the
aliquot in the morning when we come in
at 7 00 a.m and run the sepsis diaper
all right wonderful we have one final
question have you seen three organisms
in the same bottle yeast gpc at gnb and
how did maldi report it out
so we have had poly microbes in in our
bottles but like i said
in the presentation that is not
something we would put on the moldy so
that would just be something we would
just report out the three organisms that
we see for the gram stain and we would
wait and see what grows the next day and
then we can use our organisms and put
those on the multitask the next day for
identification
perfect thank you well thank you again
felicia for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor brooker
daltonix for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye
you